what is going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data
and if this is your first time here my
name is richard and this is the channel
where we talk about all things data data
science statistics and programming so
subscribe for all kinds of content just
like this if you haven't already and hit
the notification bell so youtube
notifies you whenever i upload a video
so we're going to talk about a topic
here today that i think is a little bit
polarizing
and i say that because
i've seen a lot of youtube videos on
this topic where
uh you get a lot of interesting like to
dislike ratios and comments on them but
we're gonna be talking about remote work
here today
so
this is something that's been around for
quite some time actually in fact i had
some personal experience with it even
before the pandemic happened
but a lot of companies even if they were
more reluctant to go this route they
were sort of forced to
uh last year and so i'm sure a lot of
you you may be coming into the workforce
or into data science right now and you
may be a little bit confused about
what's the state of the workplace as far
as this is concerned and what does it
look like going forward
so we're going to talk about all that
here today we're going to talk about as
far as technologists data science and
just as much as we can speak to this
more broadly
what's the state of remote work right
now where does it look like things are
trending going forward what's the
upsides
but then also is it the rosy picture
that it may be painted out to be is that
the case we're going to dissect all of
that
so before we get into things here smash
the like button for the youtube
algorithm and then if you guys would
like to go above and beyond to support
my channel i will have links in the
description to my patreon and paypal
accounts as well as to my crypto wallet
addresses now without further ado let's
get started
so the first thing that we're going to
look at here is the sentiment reports
that dice does just about every quarter
on tech professionals tech professionals
in this context including data
scientists but
speaking a little bit more broadly here
so
with these online surveys obviously you
do have to take them with a little bit
of a grain of salt just just in terms of
having a representative sample
the way the question is framed and the
fact here that you can select multiple
answers
so
obviously there are some caveats to play
with that but
the red line here indicates the q2 2021
sentiment survey here and the question
was surrounding the desirability of
remote or flexible work
flexible meaning some kind of
combination between in-office and remote
work
and now in some contexts actually
remote may mean you're strictly working
from your home or remote could be you
can literally work from any place in the
in the country or in the world that you
want
obviously there's a little bit of some
legal gray areas there i know some
states they have some
tax restrictions uh when you're working
from another state
international you're getting into all
kinds of problems with that but for the
sake of this question
59 reported they
find it desirable to do full-time remote
work with 59 reporting they find it
desirable to do some kind of combination
of in-office slash remote work
so so there's a majority there for sure
and unsurprisingly there is a bit of a
uh age gap here so for instance
94 of younger technologists that is
those between 18 and 34 years old found
a hybrid workplace either somewhat very
or extremely desirable compared to 84
percent of those aged 35 uh or older
so it's interesting when you get into a
breakdown of the desired number of
remote work days again the red line here
indicates uh the q2 survey
and you see only 29
want to do
full on a hundred percent five days a
week
um
then so on and so forth you've got 24
wanting three days a week 22 wanting two
days a week it goes on now it's
interesting that in q4 anyway that
number that wanted five days a week was
at 41
so
you're looking at just based on one cert
going from one survey to another a 12
drop off there so
maybe that's an early indication that
that there's a bit of a momentum shift
there tough to say
but
i will say just some just some
interesting
points that they make here which we're
going to visit revisit this later but
they point out 51 percent of
technologists said that remote work made
it harder to develop and maintain
working relationships with colleagues
and that's up from 40 percent around
this time last year and that 34 claimed
they were having difficulty maintaining
an effective relationship with their
manager
now that's a really important one right
there because there's there's almost a
cliche out there about people don't
leave their job they leave their boss
so that's that's a really
that's a really concerning one i do
think
but then you also have this question
about remote work and company culture
now this is one that resonates with me a
little bit because i've seen firsthand
myself how important culture is either
towards making or completely destroying
a company and so
uh the question was how much do you
agree or disagree with the statement a
significant number of employees working
remotely is a detriment to company
culture and you still see that most
people disagree with this statement
like again with the red line here
representing the q2 2021 sentiment
you've got 29 to
plus 24
that's 53
disagreeing with that statement but
again that's a
fairly
noticeable drop off from this time last
year which would have been 23 plus 37
that is 60 percent
still though i mean there is a majority
disagreeing with that statement so we're
just gonna have to wait and see over
time to see does this kind of stabilize
here does it does it change in one
direction or another
uh only time will tell i suppose
and now we're going to look at an
article from computer world that sort of
expands on the points made in the dice
report
and they make the case in this article
that the future of work is going to be
some kind of hybrid and remote framework
so they start off by sort of restating
some of the some of the metrics that
were discussed in the dice report for
instance 59
think both remote and hybrid options are
similarly as desirable
29 of people want to be fully remote
so now the question is why do people
like the remote framework and what do
they need
well first of all employees like the
cost effectiveness and flexibility of
remote working
and that one's easy to understand so if
before you were
driving for 30 minutes to an hour twice
a day
to go to work i don't think anybody's
gonna complain about getting that time
and getting that gas money back
um there are people finding the lack of
distraction boosts productivity
now that one is probably going to be a
little bit subjective and it's going to
depend on the individual because for
some people you go to work and you get
people bugging you all the time you get
distracted because you're going in a
cafeteria and then there's people there
you get to talking there's people coming
up to your desk all the time and just
asking questions
and getting that time back is a good and
and the switching cost that that's
associated there getting all that time
back is a good thing
but there's some people where you sit
them at home and there's nothing pulling
them away from twitter and from
instagram and from all these other
things uh you got your kids bugging you
all the time that's some people so
that one is gonna be a little bit
subjective and every person has to make
a truly honest uh judgment call on that
one but either way people are seeming to
find themselves happier and more
efficient than before
and so there have been arguments that
working remotely can damage
work-life balance
like presumably because
maybe in the past there was kind of this
detachment between work and home right
like some people would go to work
they'll leave at four or five or six
then they'd come home and they're done
they're just not
associating themselves with work anymore
whereas now if you're home all the time
those barriers are are
removed
or it could be your boss is kind of
bugging you more and more because
they're already bugging you from home so
they kind of take some extra liberty and
they're bugging you
off hours so i guess these concerns have
been raised before but for most
employees the reverse actually seems to
be the case and apparently
three-quarters of tech workers feel that
their work-life balance is better or the
same as it was before the pandemic
compared to 24 who claim that work-life
balance has has declined
but i think the single most important
point is this part down here about
people are going to vote with their feet
like for instance in this survey they
found 48 percent of technologists are
interested in finding new employment
opportunities as they emerge from the
pandemic
and see this is a very important point
just because
over the course of last year a lot of
people just got that exposure to working
remotely
and so
you take people who are working remotely
right then if you're if their company is
telling them oh hey you got to go back
in the office now but they don't want to
well that's probably a case where a lot
of people maybe they stick that out for
a few months but if working remotely
really is important to them and they're
not getting that option
they're going to find that opportunity
in the marketplace somewhere providing
of course you have a strong and solid
economy where there's robust jobs or at
least there are for tech workers but
then it's not even if your company's
forcing you back in the office you could
be somebody who is working permanently
remotely and then you're going out there
and you're looking for other
opportunities that are fully remote i
mean by that point might as well right
so this is going to be a really
important point just just from a
competitive standpoint going forward
here just because a lot of companies
they may get really scared here that if
they force uh their employees back in
the office whether it's for company
culture or not they are going to lose
some of their best talent so they're
they're kind of going to have their
hands tied on this one
now i want to look at this piece from
vox
and they're breaking down the same
question of
whether the future of work is remote or
hybrid
but this piece is probably a little bit
more skeptical than the last one
and so i want to go down to this uh
study data from mckenzie they wanted to
break down uh by task what percentage of
these activities can be done remotely
without productivity loss by category
so
in my channel i focus mostly on data
analytics and data science
and when you think about the categories
of tasks that we do naturally this is
not a perfect match at all but
you think about updating knowledge and
learning 82
uh of those tasks can be done remotely
without productivity loss
70 percent for interacting with
computers
54 for processing analyzing and
interpreting information so majority of
all that stuff uh you've got no problem
but then you've got thinking creatively
now i will say about data science if
it's done properly
it is a extremely creative field
and there's definitely something
valuable about if you're trying to come
up with some novel idea
the people on your team whether it's
multi-disciplinary or not sitting
together in front of a white board where
you can draw things out and everybody's
looking at the same thing
that's not something you need to do
every single day of every week
necessarily but that is a that is an
example where there is probably some
value to being in an office environment
we've got communicating with and guiding
colleagues or clients at 43
we'll get to that one a little bit more
later but
again a lot of this stuff a lot of stuff
that data scientists do it falls under
these categories here except for
training teaching coaching and
developing others that's all the way
down there at six percent and i i
understand that one as far as why
exactly
people are as productive remotely as
they are in person like in an office
again a lot of it you could boil down to
the subjective
uh whether people are distracted or not
but i think a lot of it probably comes
down to a paradigm shift too i think a
lot of people in the past
falsely equated time in an office with
being productive and getting work done
and that's not always the case when
you're working remotely you do
completely have to shift your your
framing of productivity to what you're
actually creating and producing
if you're even just
shifting your thinking towards this is
what's valuable and this is what's
actually gener generating some kind of
business impact
that shift in and of itself is going to
be valuable
lastly though i do want to move into
this blog here that breaks down why for
some people anyway working remotely is
not all sunshine and roses
so that's just something to keep in mind
and really think about particularly if
you're somebody who's just now getting
into data science or into the workplace
in general
so
what are the reasons for that
number one you will feel left out
occasionally
now this is an interesting one that i
have actually experienced
not personally but i've seen other
people experiencing firsthand i did work
at an organization in the past where
there were a combination of in-person
and totally remote workers
and the remote workers did seem to be
the ones who who just had the least
uh just fulfillment and happiness there
so they
they just felt left out of the overall
company left out of strategic uh
decisions and influence over the company
as a whole
so
it depends a little bit on the overall
culture and how exactly they're they're
treating remote employees i guess
but this is just a fair one to keep in
mind
number two networking is much harder for
remote workers
so this is actually
related to a separate point which is
their business travel right now in the
post pandemic era is way down
so if if business travel is at all
discretionary like conferences tend to
be
uh right now they're just being cut
because a lot of employers they just
don't want to deal with all of that and
all the risks and potential liabilities
associated with it
uh and then even when there are trips
they're getting scaled down considerably
and when that happens yeah that is going
to cut down on networking
so
this is this is just another one to uh
just another risk here to keep in mind
then you've got productivity
expectations may differ
um again this one is probably related to
the paradigm shift i mentioned before if
you were used to in the past you were
going into work and then you weren't
doing anything there but you felt like
you were productive just because you
were going in the office
well that might may not be the case
anymore
now this is a huge one
it can get lonely
now again this is this is one that's
going to be highly subjective
um there are people who are very
extroverted and they need to be out
there just in an office talking to
people all the time and i'm not i'm not
saying that like there's anything wrong
with that kind of framework in fact i
personally like being in a hybrid
environment because sometimes again i
like to cut down on the uh commute time
and all that kind of stuff as much as
anybody but i personally identify as a
pretty strong extrovert myself and so i
do like to interact and engage with
people so that's why the hybrid approach
is personally perfect for me
some people are really heavy on the on
the extrovert side
but there's also the
the the extreme on the other end which
is the heavy introverts
and now i have to extend a point of
caution on that one
because it is absolutely true there are
a lot of people out there who have in
historically anyway
derived a strong sense of community and
maybe family to an extent
uh from the from the office
uh dynamics that they experience
and now there's a and there's also a lot
of people that they are introverted and
if they don't have to go into an office
they're not going to have to even if
as far as their mental health and
overall well-being is concerned that
would overall be a good thing for
getting them out of their shell
so i have to just caution you on this
one if you're that type of person who
you
just benefit from going out and
interacting with people but you won't
you wouldn't unless you're forced to
working remotely could absolutely
destroy you in that sense so
you have to be really really dead honest
with yourself on that one if you're
falling on either of those two extremes
now if you're somebody who that doesn't
apply to you you have your sense of
community from your family or from your
church or from something else and you
really don't need
that kind of quality from your workplace
that's that's absolutely fine but if
previously you did
just get a really set a real sense of
community
from going in an office really be honest
with yourself about that
you've got self-directed learning
suddenly becomes crucial this one is
probably understandable because i'm
skeptical about is your boss going to
sit there and in on a longer more
extended microsoft teams or zoom call to
really hone in on your personal and
professional development i have my
doubts
uh remote work is a skill so
we'll have to explore this one a little
bit further in the future but i mean
that that is something that maybe you
could pipe yourself up on on on your
resume or in interviews maybe you did a
really really good job and you can
demonstrate that your productivity was
enhanced uh when you got the opportunity
to work remotely well if you can show
that then that's that's absolutely a net
positive so take advantage of that
and then as i was alluding to before
working remotely is not for everyone and
increasingly it looks like it's going to
be difficult to find a
a any kind of framework that's going to
work for everybody
and so if you were to ask me what i
think about the future of data science
work and is remote work in general a
good or a bad thing
i'd say the answer to that is there
really is no answer
i say that because number one the
conditions of the pandemic are changing
constantly nobody knows what that's
going to look like one year or five
years down the road
a lot of employers are a little confused
right now they're trying to react to
constantly changing conditions
they're trying to experiment with
different things to come up with an
ideal hybrid framework
and something that's going to support
their company culture as well as their
remote employees
but then employee preferences are very
different as you saw some do want to be
in an office all the time but
more people than not want to be remote
or hybrid so there's absolutely no one
solution out there that's going to
please everybody
and just this combination of factors i
think over the next three to five years
is going to contribute to a lot of just
uncertainty and just people
experimenting with different things and
the overall business climate changing
pretty rapidly
but for data scientists especially those
of you with a little bit more experience
i do think there's tons of reason for
encouragement here
so it's clear there's all this remote
work out there now that there's never
been in the past
and if you're somebody who's not
thrilled with your current employment
situation
whether you want to be in a remote
framework but your employer's forcing
you back in the office or honestly for
any other reason
there's tons of opportunities out there
that are going to allow you to to work
remotely
and even if you're somebody who wants to
stay in your current geographical
location like your state or your city
you have all this opportunity that could
be available to you that's that's in
different states maybe even in different
countries who knows
so there's all kinds of opportunity
available to you if you have skills that
are valuable in the marketplace which i
guarantee you that you do if you're a
proficient data scientist and you're
willing to put yourself out there
so i'll leave it at that
thanks for watching this video if you
enjoyed it please take a fraction of a
second to smash the like button
if you want to read any of these
articles that i went over in this video
they'll all be linked in the description
then i'll see you all in the not so
distant future
until then
richard on data